(soft music)
- [Dasl] This tender moment
between North Korea leader
Kim Jon Un and his daughter
stole the spotlight
of a military parade in Pyongyang
as the country showed off weapons,
it says are capable of
hitting the US mainland.
And this was the fifth time since November
that the public has seen Kim Jong believed
to be the leader's second child.
She's been seen holding
hands with her father
and being surrounded by
senior military officials.
And her appearances have raised
questions about why she's
in the public eye now and
whether she could become
the next leader.
We take a look at how
Kim Ju Ae is presented
in North Korea propaganda
and her significance
to the regime.
(soft music)
So Kim Ju Ae first appeared
at an ICBM launch in November.
Kim Ju appeared with her father
holding hands and basically
surprising the world
because we had never seen
one of the Kim children before.
(cameras clicking)
Since then, she has appeared
at multiple military events
instead of appearing like they
are spending loads and loads
of money on military
equipment and missiles.
Bringing the daughter to
these events helps portray
Kim Jong Un as a father who is
trying to protect the nation
with the weapons that they possess.
Since North Korea first revealed
that they had their nationwide outbreak,
North Korea is struggling economically
and there have been restrictions to trade.
(rocket launching)
Despite all of that,
we had a record number of
missile launches in 2022.
Analysts say that they
need domestic support
for many of the missile
launches that they're doing.
She is a symbol of the next generation
that the regime has to protect
with the weapons that they have.
(upbeat music)
So bringing Kim Ju to
these military events
it not only helps soften
the image of the military
it also portrays Kim Jong
Un as a loving father.
Kim Jong Un does want to appeal
to the public as a more generous
and a more caring figure.
So ever since Kim Ju Ae appeared in public
there has been a lot
of talk about succession
plans in North Korea.
So it's very significant to see how
senior North Korean officials
will shake her hand,
bow to her,
be very respectful towards her
despite her being a nine
to 10 year old child.
But on the other hand, some analysts say
that it might not be likely
that a female becomes the
leader of North Korea.
With North Korean leaders,
there are these signs of portraying them
as being very different
from ordinary people.
And for now,
the way we've seen state media
portray Kim Ju Ae has been
as a child, as a daughter,
as someone who Kim Jon
Un is trying to protect.
Kim Jong Un is only
39-years-old, and analysts say
that it's still too early
for him to name a successor.
Both his father
and his grandfather
ruled until their deaths
and it's likely that Kim Jong
Un is going to do the same.
(soft music)